mathieu asselin d'abord aidez nous à
comprendre baie du nord pourquoi le
gouvernement dit oui est ce qu'il
pouvait faire autrement
mais simplement je pense que tu es à ces
déchirants on a vu au cabinet qui s'est
passé divisés mais moi j'écoute je
prends la parole du ministre de
l'environnement qui a dit que il avait
déterminé que les taxes
environnementales étaient à son habit
minimale donc il ya eu beaucoup d'études
techniques qui ont été faits et j'ai pas
d' expertise spécifique dans le dossier
spécifique mais tout ce que je peux vous
dire c'est que le gouvernement je pense
à pester d'avoir posé là mais vous qui
avez été au gouvernement quand même
plusieurs années vous savez très bien
comment un gouvernement doit composer au
canada quatrième producteur de pétrole
du monde mais en même temps avec des
exigences environnementales qui sont
très importants est-ce que c'est
contradictoire par rapport
à l'engagement du canada de réduire ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
cela parce que l'industrie pétrolière au
canada il ya beaucoup de gens qui en
doute mais résolument engagé dans sa
transition énergétique
évidemment elle va avoir besoin de
l'aide du gouvernement fédéral en
innovation par exemple pour avoir des
procédés qui sont moins polluants et ça
je pense qu'il faut être conscient que
ça va pas être fait du jour au lendemain
ça va prendre un certain temps et si ce
que monsieur guilbeault dalphond a dit
aujourd'hui ses cli confiant qu'avec une
mère de la biotechnologie des meilleurs
procédés et des comme vous dites des
examens plus rigoureux aussi dépossédé
on va enlever à polluer moins mais de
l'idée que de jour au lendemain on peut
juste tourner aof la switch et qu'on pût
ali a d'autre chose que du pétrole à
court terme je pense que fait illusoire
daniel béland vous en pensez quoi quelle
est votre analyse de cette décision sur
baie du nord
malgré ces pour surprenant on suit ce
qui s'était passé avec le projet
transmettent une par exemple où le
gouvernement fédéral a acheté le projet
à l'ordre c'est pour la première fois
que les libéraux se font critiqué par
les environnementalistes
c'est sûr que c'est un grand pays canada
on a des régions qui dépendent beaucoup
encore des énergies extractives et si le
code d'un terre-neuve et labrador vous
savez c'est la province la plus endettée
au pays c'est aussi une province il faut
pas oublier qu'un premier ministre elle
vous ferez qui est libéral six des sept
députés fédéraux sont à des députés
libéraux et la situation économique
l'abord et quand même ou 6 1 en juin
donc l'enjeu environnemental qui est
très important mais l'enjeu économique
est tout aussi important d'un point de
vue ici régionales il faut pas l'oublier
aussi le terre-neuve-labrador c'est un
grand producteur d'hydroélectricité
c'est une province qui en termes
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre ces
minuscules comparées par exemple albert
thomas en ontario et au québec en partie
parce qu'un une population réduite donc
il ya plusieurs facteurs ici le savez
terre-neuve-labrador les produits
seulement 5% ce pétrole au canada loin
derrière l'alberta et même la
saskatchewan qu'un produit 10% donc il
faut remettre en perspective
mais c'est sûr que les rovers et peu
importe ce qu'ils font parce que s'ils
avaient dit non aux fruits certain que
il y aurait eu beaucoup de critiques
tana non seulement des policiers à
temps plein terre-neuve et au labrador
mais aussi des gens n'a réussi
pétrolière ailleurs au pays je vous
emmène sur le budget qui sera présenté
demain robert asselin que eu lieu il ya
plus de revenus de toute évidence la
croissance économique est plus forte
qu'attendu l'inflation justement les
prix du pétrole le pétrole qui rapporte
beaucoup à l'état canadien est ce que le
gouvernement doit va dépenser davantage
on dirait que la liste d'épicerie et
quand même longue oui c'est ma crainte
nous supplions comment utiliser cette
situation économique un peu artificielle
artificielle parce que l'inflation vous
venez de le dire dans des revenus niveau
du pib nominal n'était pas attendu le
cours du pétrole aussi dans beaucoup de
revenus ou grands fédéral et qu'on va
utiliser ses revenus gonflés à l'hélium
un peu pour dépenser et introduire des
programmes structurels des programmes
sociaux et je pose pas de jugement sur
la valeur de ces programmes tout ce que
je dis c'est que ces programmes là vont
devoir être financé à terme et que dans
deux trois ans on n'aurait peut-être pas
la croissance qu'on a aujourd'hui
d'après la pandémie ce que je crains
aussi c'est un manque de focus ensemble
c'est allé beaucoup vous vous rappelez
puis l'ims elle avait dit qu'à lancer
ses consultations prébudgétaires
j'aime m'occuper de la croissance
économique la compétitivité c'est le
focus de ce budget là aujourd'hui qu'on
entend c'est c'est le logement c'est le
sait la défense
de jugement de valeur c'est chaud la
liste s'allonge en même temps c'est
nécessaire d'investir dans l'accès à la
propriété ou dans l'accès au logement
notamment pour les premières nations
dans la défense quand l'otan nous d'y
arriver à 2% il faut investir dans la
défense le coût de la vie qu'est ce
qu'on fait comment les canadiens se
affronte le coût de la vie je veux
laisser la parole à daniel béland là
dessus non je suis d'accord qu'il ya
beaucoup d'enjeux c'est vrai que si un
seul danger que on s'éparpille beaucoup
mais l'inflation les gens sont très
pluie par l'inflation évidemment la
guerre en ukraine des pressions pour
augmenter les dépenses militaires à au
moins 2 % du pib sont très fortes et
donc savoir on va aller dans cette
direction là et aussi faut pas l'oublier
l'entente avec le npd l'entente dont
kill bées roux le npd un vent évidemment
produire une augmentation encore plus la
paix des dépenses sociales notamment
quand on parle la question de
l'assurance dentaire par exemple pour
les plus démunis donc il faut s'attendre
à pas mal de mes
c de l'éparpillement daniel béland de
faire ça ou c'est profond régal
le problème c'est que dès les pressions
se multiplient entre le port on je pense
que pour ce qui est de la décence hurle
ce serait très difficile de paul faire
parce que les pays qui tiraient de
l'arrière cld ans au sein de l'otan
comme comme par exemple l'allemagne ont
décidé d'augmenter aux dépenses
militaires de façon importante en raison
de l'invasion russe de l'ukraine et je
pense que le pauvre et man show et ce
niveau lors la pandémie au jour lors
l'inflation ppi l'entente inclut un
donc s'il rêve et c'est on va voir on
n'a pas encore vu le budget moi j'ai pas
accès évidemment vous non plus un mais
mais il pourrait avoir des surprises
mais si mais si un danger il faut voir
c'est toujours difficile à un budget
c'est que le jour il ya tellement de de
compromis qu'il faut faire les tellement
de priorité potentiel est un exercice
périlleux l'on va voir si le deuxième
budget de madame julienne et je lui
souhaite bonne chance ok c'est ce qu'on
verra vous voulez quelque chose de
fondamental quand même robert asselin
c'est à dire de favoriser la croissance
économique à long terme peut-être laissé
tomber la relance qui avait été annoncée
l'an passé de 100 milliards sur trois
ans alors que l'économie taux plafond en
ce moment comment on fait sauf favoriser
la croissance économique à long terme
est-ce qu'il faut stimuler en ce moment
c'est l'investissement privé c'est ça
qui manque dans l'économie on peut faire
ça en favorisant des politiques
d'innovation
numérisation des entreprises on ne s'est
pas déjà
oui on fait mais il faut le faire plus
sérieusement je pense notre politique
industrielle
d'apple elle a besoin d'un coup de pouce
le plus moderne il pour garder ce que
les américains font un secteur des
espaces par exemple ça car de la défense
utilise des options bien rodée au goût
de la recherche et développement et pour
nos secteurs de pointe soit plus
stimulée l'agriculture par exemple
beaucoup de potentiel pour le canada
avec la technologie le cleantech avec le
secteur énergétique évidemment les
charges la vie monsieur champagne a pas
beaucoup le fameux bibliothèque je pense
qu'on peut faire mieux là et je veux
juste dire une chose qui était important
sur la politique budgétaire entre nantes
et en essence c'est que la politique
monétaire et c'est d'amener les frais
parce que l'on a des relations qui n'est
pas contrôlée qui plus soutenue et d'un
politique budgétaire qui va à contre
sens il m'a par un portable court terme
c'est pas par de dommages et pas
accélérer le mouvement de la banque
centrale de l'autre côté donc il faut
jouer de prudence à mon avis à court
terme ok c'est ce que nous verrons
demain au budget robert asselin merci
daniel béland merci beaucoup merci à toi
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
oh